c'est une start-up incubés au ski cub
depuis 2010 8 6 kg au développent cette
cabine de relaxation après un tour de
france et une levée de fonds en 2019
cette start up a été frappé de plein
fouet par la crise sanitaire pour en
parler nous sommes avec son fondateur
hervé mation bonjour bonjour merci
nicolas nous accueillir
on a passé deux ans extrêmement
difficile avec cette crise sanitaire on
a essayé de jouer notre rôle à travers
la crise puisque on a mis nos cabines à
disposition des soignants et ça c'était
par contre une vraie expérience
maintenant je vous cache pas qu'on est
heureux d'être là aujourd'hui parce que
parce que financièrement ça a été très
difficile ça avec eux on nous a
indirectement interdit de travailler
donc pour une startup c'était compliqué
j'étais obligé de reprendre un travail
voilà donc c'est d'autant plus difficile
c'est qu'il faut travailler dans
l'entreprise puisse essayer de de
relever cette start-up parce qu'on peut
pas abandonner c'est un projet qui est
vraiment qu'il ya tellement d'impact qui
marche tel tellement bien que l'on peut
pas s'arrêter là vous êtes un
entrepreneur un des entrepreneurs
français qui avait fait face finalement
alors comme beaucoup malheureusement
mais il faut savoir que 80 % des
startups françaises ont été impactés par
par la crise malheureusement il ya
encore aujourd'hui beaucoup de startups
qui sont en train de déposer le bilan
j'ai des propres collègues qui ont
investi cinq ans de leur vie parfois
deux cent mille euros de leur poche et
qui sont en train de tout perdre donc
c'est une vraie difficulté vous êtes
présent aujourd'hui au tech innove c'est
la relance c'est la reprise d'activité
ça y est alors la reprise je dirais pas
que c'est la reprise mais en tout cas
déjà ça nous fait du bien de repartir
dans ce projet
j'ai presque ému de vous dire ça mais
oui
ç'a failli s'arrêter disons oui
c'était extrêmement difficile et savez
c'est des gens comprennent pas en fait
les start up il pense que une start up
c'est des gens à qui bricolent dans leur
jardin ce qui est pas faux à la base
très souvent ce sont des ingénieurs sont
des férus de technologie mais il oublie
une chose c'est que ce sont avant tout
c'est des investisseurs on met beaucoup
de temps mais on met aussi beaucoup
d'argent mois ses trente ans de ma vie
c'est 30 ans d'économies de ma vie de de
carrière que j'ai mis là-dedans
financièrement j'ai un pacte et des gens
aussi j'ai des investisseurs personnelle
des gens qui ont mis de l'argent vous
n'avez pas le droit en fait de les
décevoir et donc oui oui c'est très très
difficile il a ça y est vous voyez
disons le bout du tunnel ou pas tout va
dépendre de ce qui va se passer derrière
ce qu'on va être confiné ou pas mais oui
enfin on espère et en tout cas les
rendez-vous qu'on ait aujourd'hui j'ai
pas arrêté depuis aujourd'hui la cabine
a été plein donc donc oui on sent qu'un
intérêt il ya des investisseurs qui sont
venus on amène les canadiens qui sont
venus nous voir donc donc voilà je pense
qu'il ya un vrai havre et intérêts
j'espère que ça va nous relancer un
petit peu quoi merci r b nation merci
beaucoup à vous rappelle fondateur de 6
kg au la cabine de relaxation incubés au
ski cube